en este vídeo hablaremos de la
composición de funciones y si escribimos
la notación la función f círculo g de x
observen que esto no es el símbolo de
multiplicación este es un círculo un
poco más grande y tampoco es la palabra
forma muchas personas se confunden con
eso y no sé de qué me hablan pero en
realidad se lee
efe deje tx y esta anotación significa
que tenemos una función de g de x e
igualmente en el caso de g de fx tenemos
a fx adentro de g ahora la composición
es algo que muchas veces puede llegar a
confundir así que veamos un par de
ejemplos
vamos a ver supongamos que fx es igual a
x cuadrada más x y supongamos que gdx es
igual a 4 menos
x ok entonces supongamos que queremos
conocer f
x eso significa que en realidad queremos
conocer
efe de gdx así que podemos sustituir gx
porque lo conocemos gx es igual a 4 - x
ok ya tenemos a efe deje de x
y supongamos que alguien les pide que
calculemos efe de 3 que es lo que haría
bueno simplemente regresamos a la
función f x que teníamos al inicio y
donde sea que tengamos una equis la
vamos a sustituir por el número 3
entonces si regresamos a donde estábamos
donde sea que tengamos una equis vamos a
reemplazarla pero esta vez no vamos a
sustituir únicamente un número sino que
más bien nos dicen que debemos sustituir
por 4 menos x esta es la idea de la
composición de funciones en lugar de
solamente sustituir por un número
podemos sustituir una expresión más
complicada ok y ahora vamos a
simplificar esto es igual a 4 menos x x
4 menos x más 4 menos x
entonces esto es igual a 4 por 4 que es
igual a 16
4 por x que es igual a menos 4x y
nuevamente menos 4 por x que es igual a
menos 4x y después menos x por menos x
es igual a x cuadrada y después tenemos
más cuatro menos x y esto es igual a x
cuadrada la escribimos primero y después
tenemos menos 4 x 4 x que es igual a
menos 8 x menos otra x eso es igual a
menos 9 x así ya juntamos todos los
términos que contienen x y finalmente 16
más 4 es igual a 20 esa sería la
composición
efe deje de x ahora hagamos una
variación de esto nuevamente tenemos que
fx es igual a x cuadrada más x y que x
es igual a 4 - x pero ahora queremos
encontrar g
fx y miren recuerden que en la
multiplicación no importa el orden 2 x 3
es lo mismo que 3 por 2 pero observen
que en esta anotación parece como si
fuera una multiplicación pero no lo es
así que debemos ser muy cuidadosos
porque no obtendremos el mismo resultado
aquí obtuvimos que f deje de x es igual
a todo eso pero veamos qué es lo que
obtenemos cuando calculamos g de fx
entonces nuevamente esta anotación
significa que vamos a sustituir f x en
la función de g y como fx es la función
x cuadrada más x la colocamos ahí y por
ejemplo si les dicen encuentra g de 2
bueno donde sea que tengamos x vamos a
sustituirla por el valor de 2 pero en
este caso donde sea que tengamos una
equis vamos a sustituirla por todo esto
x cuadrada más
así que esta es la composición de la
función g de fx y si hacemos la
distribución nos queda menos x cuadrada
menos x + 4 esa es la composición y
miren obtuvimos algo muy diferente esto
es lo que obtuvimos en f deje de x y
esto fue lo que obtuvimos en g de fx son
dos cosas totalmente diferentes por eso
hay que tener cuidado ahora supongamos
que en el problema nos piden encontrar g
df de 3 ok
primero necesitamos encontrar g de fx
que fue lo que hicimos aquí y ahora
simplemente necesitamos sustituir las x
por el número 3
así nos queda menos 3 al cuadrado menos
3 más 4
3 al cuadrado es 9 así que tenemos menos
9 menos 34 y menos 9 menos 3 es igual a
menos 12 y más 4 eso es igual a menos 8
esta es nuestra solución entonces esta
es la idea básica de la composición de
funciones prácticamente consiste en
poner una función adentro de otra espero
que estos ejemplos les sirvan y los
invito a que vuelvan a hacerlos por su
cuenta si es que aún no los entiende